when you look back at this you know
decade of work or more now what do you
think is at the core of creating
startups well I mean I think being a
founder the most important thing really
the kind of meta-level important thing
is to know yourself I think most people
do not spend enough time understanding
themselves and understanding what are
you good at and what are you not good at
and for the things that you're good at
how do I like focus on those things and
do more of them and for the things
you're not good at how do I either
improve or how do I delegate those to
someone else I think most founders hit a
wall because they're doing something it
starts working and then they don't get
out of their own way you know they are
they insist they think because I created
the product and I wore it which there's
a heavy dose of survivorship bias there
I am gonna like I all my decisions are
right so I want to micromanage kind of
all these other parts of my company or I
want to be have to make all these
decisions or my ego is such that I don't
get out of the way of these other people
I brought into the company to let them
operate and I feel like that's a very
common problem that I see all the time
and this problem that I've had in my
life throughout my life that I've you
know kind of only you know in the last
maybe five or six years really
understood deeply so is that
self-awareness you know and identifying
your superpower yeah what's your
superpower what are you showing us on
that I'm a very good salesperson I think
I'm a very good hype man I think I'm
very you know so that applies to all the
sales like things of fundraising
recruiting sales you know actual sales I
think those are those are that's kind of
one of my superpowers I think I also
have a like a very deep well of
confidence that you know myself
and the right people can build anything
you said your mind to and I think that's
uh that really has put me on the path to
like say oh whatever startup it is I
could figure that out see that is those
are superpowers that I think people
sometimes underestimate the value of
yeah because the ability to sell and get
people to pay attention to what you're
doing is such an amazing superpower I
share that superpower with them it's
like kind of why we vibe I think it's
because getting people to just even
recognize the existence of what you're
doing in such a busy world
exactly but then combining it with the
blind faith that it's all gonna work out
and don't worry
exactly see I added that skill later in
life to where I just said listen I
looking back on the last one here it's
like it's always worked out so let's not
assume that it's not gonna work out
let's assume it's gonna work out
yeah right and then justin.tv probably
just burned that it's like into your
then you have to have faith I always
tell people you know when I was a
partner on Y Combinator you know I would
spend time telling every class that came
in now I would tell my group look here's
my story if we can do it you have no
excuse cuz this is the stupidest idea
with people who had no skills who went
through an eight-year journey that
mostly P would have given up on and then
on the back end of it created something
pretty amazing and so you know you have
to have that confidence and you have to
have that self belief you know even if
you're kind of taking on faith